the loud house became one of the top
Nickelodeon shows in just a year after
its first release while this
family-friendly show seems to be doing
pretty well in the cartoon world there
are a lot of Secrets you might not know
about the loud house stay tuned to hear
more about season 3 and why Chris Savino
got fired from his own show give this
video a thumbs up if you love the loud
house and don't forget to subscribe to
our Channel now let's find out
everything that's wrong with the loud
house we hope you're ready because we
have a lot to talk about from Chris
Savino to inappropriate episode's
character stereotypes and season 3
rumors the loud house has gained quite a
fanbase but let's start this video off
with the Creator himself who's
responsible for everything related to
the loud house if you've watched any of
our other loud house videos you probably
know that the names of the show's
characters were taken directly from
Chris savino's own large family the
characters have also been totally
transformed as they were originally
supposed to be rabbits which quite
frankly wouldn't be as interesting to
watch as the creator of the show chris
is completely in charge of every single
element of the loud house or should we
say he was in charge of every single
element of the loud house in the wake of
2017 harassment reports of various
Hollywood actors producers and directors
several people also came forward and
reported on inappropriate behavior of
the loud houses very own Chris Savino it
seems almost impossible that a man
behind one of the most successful
Nickelodeon children's shows got fired
from his own project because of his
inappropriate behavior towards several
women during the course of his career
Nickelodeon issued a statement saying
that at least a dozen women came forward
and spoke up about the inappropriate
behavior on Chris's part they also
stated that they take allegations of
misconduct
very seriously and they are committed to
fostering a safe and professional
workplace environment that is free from
harassment or other kinds of
inappropriate conduct the shocking
allegations against Chris Savino dated
back several years and even included
threats of retribution after the end of
consensual relationships nickelodeon
confirmed that the family-friendly
series will continue to air without
Chris Savino stay tuned to hear how all
these allegations might also have had an
effect on some of the jokes and
storylines of the show along with
episodes that should have never aired
speaking of the storylines you have to
admit the loud house is just a strange
show we follow the lives of eleven kids
and their friends but the story mainly
revolves or
the middle child and his point of view
Lincoln's just 11 years old but for some
reason he's the one that's in charge of
the entire family we see him rushing the
girls to get ready in the morning and
even helping out with the 11 month old
baby sister well it's clear that Lincoln
loud represents Chris Savino and his own
large family we just don't understand
why he's the one that has to care more
about his siblings rather than putting
the responsibility on some of the older
kids and where are his parents in all of
this Rita and Lynne senior are hardly
around and when they are they seem to
never parent their kids as they should
we always see them either leaving the
kids or simply disappearing for a couple
of seconds in the episode Lincoln has a
lot of responsibility probably more than
any other kid cartoon character from any
shows the clear example can be seen in
the project loud house episode in the
very first couple of scenes we can see
the kids getting ready for school and
while Lincoln is trying really hard to
keep his school project safe the rest of
the kids are going through the usual
morning chaos but it seems like Lincoln
is the one that has to keep the kids
from fighting and gets them ready he's
even the one that gets the 11 month old
Lily dressed up and ready even though
she doesn't seem to listen at all where
are their parents and why aren't they
involved in the morning school run
another similar episode like that is
potty mouth where the loud kids hear
Lily say a bad word just as their
parents leave to the mall for an
interview with the daycare Academy in
order to make sure the daycare Academy
accepts them the kids try really hard to
be on their best behavior to make sure
Lily doesn't say any more bad words but
it seems like Lincoln is mostly the one
that keeps a watchful eye over Lily as
the rest of the kids show her how to be
nice while the loud house is definitely
a hilarious show it's a reminder that
sometimes the parents just aren't around
much and the child has to be the one
that takes care of the family but even
though the loud house features mainly
children it still has a lot of
inappropriate jokes and moments that
should have never been shown on
Nickelodeon maybe the TV network doesn't
know just how popular this show is and
how many young children are watching it
after just one year of air times the
loud house became a number-one show on
all TV for the month of May in 2017 the
show is extremely popular with kids from
the age of two and all the way to 11
year old the show even got its own
online based game and Nickelodeon is
promising a console game of the loud
house in the future a spokesperson
stated that the loud house has rapidly
become one of their best loved
properties and there are
plans to develop it further in the
multi-platform space sounds exciting
right but what a game be just as
inappropriate as were some of the
episodes on the show we all knew
Nickelodeon is known for raunchy jokes
that are actually meant for adults but
it seems that those jokes says don't
ever stop on this show from innuendos
two episodes that really shouldn't have
been made for kids the loud house really
knows how to make jokes and moments
extra inappropriate we've covered them
all in our the loud house episodes that
weren't for kids but here is a recap of
some of the moments that went just a
little bit over the edge at least in our
opinion
one such episode is the serial offender
in which the loud kids go to the grocery
store by themselves of course everyone
except for Lincoln goes crazy and starts
turning the story into a complete
madhouse which is something no parent
wants to see their children - it's
definitely not the most appropriate
episode for young kids especially not
when you hear Lynde say something that
will make you do a double-take to make
sure you heard it right ties that bind
is also one of those heartbreaking
episodes that we just can't approve it
all starts when Lincoln overhears as
parents talk about the fact that they're
going to get rid of them because the
trash pickup is coming to get them the
next day
Lincoln immediately thinks they're
talking about the kids and he gets even
more worried when he hears his father
say that it'll only keep the one with
the white hair the kids immediately put
on their best behavior after they admit
they're terrible children they really
get scared that they're going to get
kicked out of the house it definitely
seems that this episode might be just a
little bit too much for kids especially
those who are going through tough family
times and then there are of course all
the inappropriate jokes Nickelodeon
managed to include in the loud house
some of them were so inappropriate they
were even excluded in other countries
like the Space Invader episode all Lab
kids except for Lincoln share a room and
of course they have lots of fights in
Space Invader Lincoln offers Lynn to
share a room with him as she had a fight
with Lucy in true Lynn style she accepts
the offer and immediately goes through
his room and criticizes everything she
sees then she makes one of the most
inappropriate jokes on the show she
comments that there's a total lack of
balls in his room and that it's a good
thing she brought her own she gives a
small pause between the sentences and
you can clearly see that Lincoln gets
pretty uncomfortable with her statement
we won't tell you what nickelodeon meant
with this joke but if you're old enough
we're pretty sure you can understand why
it's
a little bit inappropriate for a kids
show if you watch the same clip from a
British Nickelodeon you'll notice that
our paws and Lincoln's expression are
completely removed
so either Lynn went too far or the UK is
just a little bit too sensitive for a
show like the loud house Lincoln really
does have a lot on his plate with such
strong personalities in his house
speaking of personalities let's focus on
the actual characters from the show the
loud kids all have unique personalities
that make it easier to tell them apart
but those personalities are so
stereotypical they often misrepresent
what it really means to have a certain
character cartoons have a history of
stereotypical characters but it seems as
the loud house kids have such specific
personalities they're almost seemed like
a cliche let's start with a four year
old Lisa loud although she still speaks
with a lisp she is one of the smartest
kids in the house let's ignore the fact
that she's just four years old and has
already won a Nobel Peace Prize and is
probably the smartest member of the loud
family Lisa is a typical science nerd
who often does weird things like ask her
family for stool samples without wanting
to reveal why everything about her fits
with a science stereotype and it seems
like that's all she contributes to the
story that's also the problem with the
six-year-old twins of the family the
characters are just too stereotypical
Lola and Lynn aloud are the typical twin
sisters who have completely different
personalities
while Lola's character shows off her
girly side Lana's is a typical tomboy
and the two never step away from their
stereotypical traits the same goes for
other characters the eight-year-old Lucy
is known as the moody one the
thirteen-year-old Lynn is the
competitive one the fourteen-year-old
Louann is the prankster and the
fifteen-year-old Luna is the musician
and then there are the two oldest ones
the sixteen-year-old Lenny who have the
typical ditzy personality and the
17-year old glory who doesn't care about
anything but her boyfriend these
character traits remain the same and
unless it's part of the storyline they
never seem to step away from their given
character traits well it's clear that
all 10 sisters seem to have unique
traits and personalities blinkin is
often criticized as the one with the
least amount of character one review of
the loud house character says that it's
Lincoln himself who lacks any real
definition fitting the boring template
of the average preteen boy it continues
to state that the show gives him some
shading when it's reveal is a comic and
TV nerd but for the most part Lincoln's
entire personality is expressed in
direct address monologues
while Lincoln might represent the
typical middle child it's on
fare to keep his personality so bland
while the rest of his sisters seem to be
totally set in their character traits
are the characters being just too
stereotypical to enjoy it's not just the
loud family that shares these
stereotypes all side characters seem to
have a personality they stick to for the
duration of the show like Clyde
Lincoln's best friend who's possibly one
of the most bizarre characters ever
we've all seen cartoon characters who
are madly in love with others to the
point of obsession but Kleiss obsession
with Laurie takes it a bit too far
especially when you include the
inappropriate jokes we've mentioned
earlier in one episode he even mentioned
he likes the sound of Laurie's toots and
says that he'll share his buns with her
it doesn't help that he's portrayed as
an only child who's jealous of Lincoln's
large family just as much Lincoln's
jealous of the fact that he's an only
child his character is just one big
stereotype that could have been
portrayed in a much more efficient way
come on Nickelodeon you can do better
than that so what do you think do you
like the loud house as of 2017 the show
is still brand new to Nickelodeon and
it's already making huge waves in the
cartoon world since Chris Savino got
fired from his own project we have a
feeling that the loud house will get new
developments and probably a couple of
crazy storylines in the next few seasons
season three has already been announced
and a Nickelodeon spokesperson commented
that it's a demonstration of the
company's continued commitment to
bringing fresh stories to their viewers
the loud house brings an impressive
viewership of two million and we bet
that number will grow even higher as the
show becomes more and more successful
season 3 will be up and running in 2018
but until then you can catch up on 90
impressive episodes of the series
will you be watching the show with Chris
Savino gone what do you think of
Lincoln's character do you like the
stereotypes on the show or would you
show them in a different way let us know
your own thoughts on the loud house in
the comments and that's it for our video
for more videos like this one check out
10 the loud house episode that weren't
for kids
see you next time